he is the general manager at the San
Francisco 49ers he's John Lynch how are
you John
I'm doing great rich how're you doing
have you ever been asked as being a
movie in a sports movie play yourself
have you ever gotten an offer I wasn't
in a sports movie there was a group of
us it was a John Travolta as you were
saying all those guys I was trying to
remember that's how that's how great of
a movie it was it was in Tampa John
Travolta we were all extras we made the
we made like the what do they call that
the outtakes or whatever that's as far
as it went but is this during they
remember the damn name of the movie so
I'm sorry is this during your baseball
days John isn't no this is when I was
playing for the Bucs and okay so you and
Bryce was in and it broke up Chris I
don't know if you got credit the
pressure the pressure well that could
have been your nickname and while you
were playing John let me start with that
one first John since you're obviously
locked in on everything going on in the
NFL as a former player and a general
manager this this rule that got passed
late in the owners meeting and now that
there's going to be a couple more days
to try and put more meat on the bones
here with the membership meeting again
about lowering your helmet and
initiating contact and that being a foul
right away and that could include
running back trying to score could
include offensive lineman trying to
block could include quarterback trying
to sneak I mean what what what can you
tell fans or or anybody about this rule
your thoughts on the John well I can
tell you that you know I was in that
room it was the head coaches general
managers and owners all in there along
with the competition committee and of
course Commissioner Goodell and it was a
spirited discussion a long discussion a
passionate discussion on both sides and
really there's not sides because
everybody wants this game to be safer
but how you implement something like
this it sounds great but how do you
actually go about and do it and you know
I think that's that's one thing I know
they're meeting here the next couple
days
and they've made great progress in terms
of defining their rule but they kind of
agreed that there should be a rule but
it's still I think they're still
figuring out exactly how to implement it
you know I know that the sentiment was
we want to have a better version of
what's been happening in college you
know I you know the one thing I did
stand up and say it you know during that
meeting is a you know at college
football while safety obviously is the
the absolute paramount motivation of
everybody college football for me became
somewhat unwatchable last year with the
targeting rule and when you you know a
game gets going you stop it for 15
minutes to look at every angle did some
part of his head I think it should be
for the egregious ones and I think you
know as a player you always knew when
somebody was out of line in terms of the
way they were playing the game and you
know I think as we continue to learn
things yes we have to we have to address
this but but we have to also know that
we play a physical sport and that's part
of the allure of it and people sign up
knowing that and so it's it's a touchy
issue I don't think anyone has the
perfect answer but we're all striving to
try to find how we can best do that now
obviously player Safety's paramount John
we all know it and I agree with you
my concern is here is we finally fixed
the catch rule okay where fans know what
if the the ultimate concept of 15 men
and women or a bar and a catch looks
like a catch if everybody thinks is a
catch it should be a catch I think we've
finally achieved that now if we're gonna
start saying it hits and might not be a
hit like what's a hit can a hit survive
the help that the the intent that's the
I mean that's a slippery slope to go
down and I was chatting on here live
with with the Commissioner prior to the
draft and mention how Richard Sherman
thinks this is gonna lead to more lower
extremity injuries and he he bristled
I'm but you're you're a former defensive
back I mean don't don't you think this
is gonna limit the ability of a
defensive back to to know where to
target what to hit here you know I've
had those concerns I do think that you
know players evolved and I think the
good thing is we've seen players adjust
their play
and they feel like it needs to go a step
further I just think he yeah you better
walk a careful line in terms of you know
not taking the the football out of
football so to speak I think you know
Richwood I believe is that the most
important steps is I as I now get to see
and they just and this was kind of quiet
with the rule out there you know the
Players Association and the NFL came
together and they've eliminated certain
helmets they now have research and for
years that was my deal you can talk
about taking to help the head out of the
game and all that but your head is
attached to your body and people are
moving very fast and so I think the
emphasis on that has been great I think
much more important and worthwhile has
been the emphasis on the technology when
you pump money and resources into the
technology you know I from the time I
played when I was eight years old to the
time I stopped playing when I was 37 the
pelvis didn't change at all and now
you're starting to see these new this
new line of helmets that are that
they've really put a lot of thought and
science and resources into
I think that's going to make it a much
safer game the rules as well and you
know I commend everyone for one to find
an answer I just think like you said
it's like how do you how do you find
that perfect answer are there going to
be some growing pains I know there will
be john lynch general manager the 49ers
here on the Rich Eisen show as for the
draft with the Raiders looking for an
offensive lineman just like you and you
draft Mike McGlinchey would you not
agree that that coin flip at the combine
was for Mike McGlinchey essentially I
know you're a big fan of Rod Woodson and
so am I so I you know he's got a job for
life but that was important you know
every shoot last year in my first draft
we saw going from pic number two to pick
number three with the trade for the
Bears which i think is going to work out
great for both franchises but there's a
it's a big deal particularly when you're
picking in the top ten I don't know
where the Raiders were going after us
but I do know that we had settled on
Mike McGlinchey being our guy and we
were sure thrilled to have the
opportunity to add him to what we're
doing here in San Francisco and in what
doing there in San Francisco has got a
lot of people excited John I don't need
to tell you there there's a certain
location where the Raiders are moving to
eventually that believes that this is a
nine win team at the very least how do
you tamp expectations I said you know I
know what we're doing right now I'm
looking at at our players on the on the
field working out and they're working
really hard and I think that's been the
message is yes we did close last year
extremely well but we got to start anew
and we got to start all over again in
terms of form and this team's identity I
do know we've improved our team both
through free agency through the draft
through undrafted free agency we're
going to be a better more competitive
Bunch
in terms of the pieces that we have both
in depth and cornerstone game-changing
players and and so that's a great thing
I think we're more explosive we're more
dynamic Jimmy's going to have a full
offseason under his belt of really
understanding the offense as opposed to
just being able to function for a game
which he did very well and so I think
there's a lot of things that have us
excited but it has not been lost on
coaching and he's done a tremendous job
with the messaging these guys that we
have to start all over and and the work
that we do and how we go about our work
you know we call it deliberate practice
if we can if we can attack this thing in
a deliberate way we'll get better each
day and give ourselves a great
opportunity to really take that moment
and we had from last year into this
season John Lynch Aaron the Rich Eisen
show what is the status of Rueben foster
John well he's going through these legal
proceedings right now and so you know as
a result of that there's not not a whole
lot I can say we've we have been strong
and what we have said about that
situation and you know it's right now
it's one that we have to sit back and
and let the legal process play itself
out them and there's been new
developments and all that and I'll leave
that to everybody to interpret to
themselves but he's not here at our
offseason workouts with our team we felt
that with the seriousness of the charges
that have been levied against him that
it was best to have Ruben trained on his
own right now but you know we yearly
await the
development says this case you know
proceeds or whatever happens in the case
and so that's that's where we are with
him have you contacted him are you in in
contact with him I don't we have been in
contact and you know Reuben still a part
of this team even though he's not
working out with us and and you know I
think you know you you get we're we're
not supposed to as a team investigate
these things but you do gather some
level of information and you know I
think we've taken the appropriate action
for the information we have right now
and we'll continue to do that one guy I
mentioned on the show yesterday that
nobody's talking about free agency is
Jerick McKinnon and what he can do in in
Shanahan system we've seen what he could
do with running backs every single place
he has been to I'm wondering how you
could tell folks other than just Jimmy G
winning what this offense is going to
look like this fall best you can tell me
on the first of May John well I think
it's gonna be pretty dynamic you know I
think we get Pierre Garcon back Marcus
Goodwin weari signed and extended him
out and he really came came out and
flourished before he had just been a
speed guy but he showed he could be more
than that Pierre was playing great
football before he got hurt you throw
Jerick McKinnon in there you throw Kyle
use check who we really figured out how
to use and I think what we have Trent
Taylor in the slot now Donte Pettis is a
guy who were extremely high on as a
receiver as a punt returner Mike
McGlinchey is thrown in there you know
we get guys back who who were injured
last year I just think there's a lot of
explosive players and and one thing Kyle
does tremendously well I think he puts
guys in positions and defenders and
positions where they have tough matchup
problems I think McKinnon is another guy
who can provide matchup problems for
opposing defenses and when we have those
guys all over the field it's going to be
tough to deal with and and so we're
excited about that and you know I think
the cool thing about Jarek even though
he's a smaller guy and a fast guy he
plays big you know we were we were had
some level of concern when you first
start looking at him because we let
Carlos Hyde walk and free agents
but you know okay we kind of had a cool
thing with Carlos being the bigger back
and Matt breda and other guys being that
smaller guy and Jarek although small in
stature he plays big he's a big you know
he plays plays like a bigger back and so
we think he can kind of be in every down
back as well so we're excited about him
so if Jimmy G wasn't on your team John
would you be after Tom Brady said he's
pleading the fifth on whether he's
appreciated would you be calling up
Belvin and trying to you know shoot the
moon one more time I'm just glad we have
Jimmy G I'm glad that that thing worked
itself out I sure was glad as this draft
was going on as this whole process that
that we in our minds have our answer
there it wasn't a bad year to be needing
a quarterback because both and free
agency and in the draft there were a lot
of options more so than typical but we
were sure pleased to have Jimmy not only
you know have made that trade but then
locked him up long term he's a part of
us and we're thrilled about that and if
you the last one for you have you
noticed what people are supposing that
that he's a free agent draw that you you
have more interest in your team because
of him no doubt about it you know last
year though you talk about having to
sell people there was one point when we
landed Pierre Garcon and and Marquis
Goodwin's
and we didn't have a quarterback and you
know that's that's a difficult
conversation stressed us guys we're
going to get you and fortunately they
listened and they believed in us and
unfortunately things came fell our way
with Jimmy and we were able to land a
guy
you know we're it is becoming a
destination and and the way to continue
to make that a destination is you know
win football games and that's what we're
working really hard to try to accomplish
this season great chat John always love
catching up with you let's let's chat
again real soon okay thankful are rich
okay you got that John Lynch at John
Lynch 49 the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience